avec une épidémie qui repart à la hausse
un avenir bien sombre pour
l'événementiel spectacles et concerts
s'annulent jour après jour sans autre
date pour les salariés intermittents les
temps sont durs 42% des entreprises
tourangelle ont dû réduire leur voilure
administrative une reprise de leur
activité semble être leur seule planche
de salut
lucas chopin
frédéric passe ses journées dans son
studio d'enregistrement de saint pierre
des corps
depuis la crise sanitaire les occasions
pour lui de sonoriser des événements
sont rares et le navire n'est pas loin
de chavirer depuis le début de la
pandémie en mars je me suis pas versé de
salaire quoi on a des aides de l'état
c'est 1200 euros par mois mais moi les
1200 euros ça ne sert à payer mon loyer
ça va faire un an fin je me suis pas
versé de salaire quoi donc ouais on aime
notre métier on y croit on tient
jusqu'au bout mais là ouais quand il ya
des commence à voir des bge énergie
quand même constat presque similaire
pour son voisin et associés anthony
gérant de l'entreprise phoenix events ça
a été compliqué c'est toujours compliqué
on se bat au quotidien sur les aides
qu'on pourrait avoir du sens pour garder
la tête hors de prix au jour le jour on
voit les projets qu'on peut qu'on peut
développer en sang
sans trop de dépenses un maximum de
rentrées d'argent toutes les semaines
leurs deux entreprises enregistrent des
concerts d'artistes locaux pour les
diffuser sur internet une façon de
garder un lien avec la culture leur
situation difficile est la même pour de
nombreux entrepreneurs du secteur de
l'événementiel la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de touraine a récemment mené
une enquête auprès d'une cinquantaine de
professionnels
verdict 80% des entreprises déplorent
plus de 50 % de perte de chiffre
d'affaires depuis avril
pourtant le président l'assurent il est
possible de concilier événement éco vite
la solution c'est déjà de ne pas arrêter
des activités dont on sait que les
gestes barrières sont pratiquées en
intérieur à partir du moment où les
manifestations se font avec le port du
masque une bonne aération
on doit pouvoir reprendre un certain
nombre d'activités globalement les plus
impactés sur les employés temporaires
ils sont 84% de moins depuis 2000 19 la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie
demande des réponses du gouvernement en
toute urgence